عندما سافرت جوليا لدراسه الكمبيوتر
والهندسه في هولندا لم تتوقع ان تواجه هي
واسرتها صعوبه في التحويل وتوفير العمله
الاجنبيه لتواجه جوليا مشاكل يوميه منذ
سته اشهر اثناء دراستها في هولندا
ان هناك
وانا قلت الاهلي انا عايزه اخذ الكارت
بتاعكم وادفع به اون لاين ادفع به اون
لاين يعني المفروض باربي
المصريين في الخارج احنا عارفين طبعا
المشكله عندنا
مشكله في مصر من شهر ثلاثه تقريبا الروسيه
فالناس اريد عارفه عارفه ان اولادي في
مشاكل في الدولار وفي مشاكل في العمله
وتوفير العمله الصعبه ايا كانت نوعها
فدلوقتي العدد احنا ممكن نقول ان هو قلب
بنسبه 50% اللي هو الناس اللي بتقدم عشان
تدرس بره ومع صعوبه تدبير العمله الاجنبيه
وفي ظل وجود سوق موازن او ما يطلق عليه
السوق السوداء فرضت البنوك العامله في مصر
قيودا مؤخرا على استخدامي بطاقات الائتمان
وخفضت حدود السحب النقدي والشراء من
الخارج بعد رصد ممارسات خاطئه باستخدام
كروت لمواطنين مقيمين في مصر لم يغادروها
في اعمال تجاريه وشراء الذهب والسحب
الدولار من الخارج
شركات السياحه كانت بتحجز
رحلاتها بطاقات الائتمان فهي بتمارس عمل
تجاري من خلال اداه استخدام شخصي فهنا فيه
سوء استخدام
غير انخفاض سعر الجنيه مقابل ارتفاع اسعار
العملات الاجنبيه قد يكون عامله جذب
للسائح الاجنبي
هل ده يؤثر على عدد السائحين الوافدين او
كذا قلت لا مش قبل 7 اشهر
اعداد المصريين المسافرين للخارج خاصه
للسياحه فضلا عن التاثير سلبي على سفر
المواطنين للعلاج اه الدراسه عند ابو
العزم العربيه القاهره